Kabira Lee I said dress this I am
awesome hey guys
Father's Day is coming up did you know
that now you do and dads are hard to buy
gifts for in my opinion so when I don't
know what to buy someone I like to make
them something so today I have some
Father's Day homemade gift ideas for you
just like your dad these gifts are kind
of chic so let's get started we'll start
here sure
get out of here get out of here please
be like me when I was younger
just get out does have a lot of things
like keys and wallet and those things
need a place so I not give your dad a
box I got this in Michael's did I get
this at Michael's no I got this at
Target just like your dad I lie
sometimes look it's got an inside oh
just like dad unexpectedly loud you're
gonna need a plain box some paint
brushes and some paint you can spray
paint the box and make it a lot easier
for yourself but we're not gonna do that
today
nope like your dad we're gonna make
things harder I'm first gonna coat the
box in a layer of gold paint if I have
paper plates let's see oh this just like
your dad sometimes I bring home trash
there we go feel free to do this in
advance if you're one of those people
that plan and like have their [ __ ] kind
up together not us Wow riveting
almost done put your dad said to your
mom that your could see ha ha what I'm
not gonna worry about the leg just like
your dad said to your mom when you were
born good enough just like your dad
thought to himself when your mom said
she's pregnant we didn't think this
through okay while this charge would
move on to the other gift dad's wear
clothes so why not make your dad a
t-shirt I had some iron-on letters and a
t-shirt I need to turn the iron on so
many thanks I'm gonna cut scissors cut
damn it just like your dad Oh totally
not prepared I'm going to cut out very
special Father's Day message this must
be a blast for you to look at unlike
your dad you had a choice to watch this
[Music]
now I'm going to lay out my message and
iron down to the shirt
[Music]
riveting hi guys sorry this is a weird
thing insert it into the middle this
video because I'm editing this video
right now and realized that my camera
battery died in the middle of it and
didn't record me showing you the final
message to the iron onto the shirt for
Father's Day here it is Dada Dada happy
Father's Day dad your gift is a shirt
for me with my name on it so you never
have to forget it again it also cut out
me showing you how I decorated the plane
box for your Dada Dada Dada we finally
has a place to put all of his feelings
and it's painted shut hey isn't this
symbolic now back to the crafts that
actually got recorded sorry my battery
died just like your dad completely
unreliable dads love wallet so well it's
a great gift feel free to make a wallet
if you have that kind of life or what
I'm doing is taking a wallet that I
already had
and I'm going to personalize it a little
bit we use this color why not I'm eating
paint because it's all I have but feel
free to use fabric markers or anything
like that again you can personalize
these any way you want but I've
personalized I like this it says where I
keep my love dad sometimes by our
affection along the same lines coasters
are something adults use I have these
plain coasters so I'm going to
personalize them tada again take your
time to personalize them any way you
want
I wrote child support because the
coasters support the beer which
sometimes feels more like a child to
father than yourself well there you go
guys there were some of my quick easy
cheap Father's Day gift ideas hopefully
this inspires you to get your dad
something from the heart
I don't know I'd know I have a great
little shift my dad and I love him very
very much so please don't read into any
of this here dad aren't you proud of the
things I'm doing of my life